yeah welcome to this video playing
someone from France not sure if I played
him before Bela Lugosi the actor played
am Dracula this really old I think it
was still black and white movies so our
Kings Indian and I play the h3 line
let's see em what is coming up with 9206
come probably Queenie eight now or are
you five one of those two moves most
people play Queenie ATM to even avoid
any kinds of D takes d5 stuff okay now
yeah White has more than one one move g4
is the sharpest move the scan the
sexually really fits well into the e5
structure if black plays with c5 we get
a very weird position that resembled
maroc see bind after black takes on d4
but white has summer play G for which is
really weird but on the other hand black
has played moves like we da 28 which is
also bad um I mean the bed kind of
square for the Queen and also a night on
on a 6 which really doesn't do much as
well so we get exactly that and now it's
the question how how am the sea untying
his pieces yeah
suddenly possibility the question is I'm
96 do I want to exchange really nights
on its there some point and numb
preparing for 926 like Bishop e3 so that
on 96 I can move from my g4 night again
yeah I'm not sure Roxy one is some 2m to
cover see form that we should be 70 some
strange move okay some continue
developing so it's really not a position
web-like aims for b5 I mean then we
should be seven looks like he's doing
that yeah he does but ok so there's some
more than one idea here I could play
very very aggressive leaves f4f 45 not
sure I can also just plain that d 5 with
a with them change of structure 95 90 x
80 85 95 um maybe you can take you for
it's not out of this world it's a
sacrifice but may be possible oh come on
let's let's go away for SS this is
somewhat risky but the idea is just e 5
and try to get something going in the
center immediately
of course them if he goes be five now e5
would also check the rook of course it's
not so easy with the bishop on g2 if you
take on a eight at some some stage then
your king is very exposed so this avoids
some suddenly em or not without risk but
at the moment that's simply you 45
threatening and the knight on f6 has no
square all square some traditional
squares for the night and blocked by
pieces and he can go 96 of course but
this also might be answered with taking
and e5 or taking and e5 or f5 at some
some later stage now he's investing some
time yeah I'm not sure about this
position it's um quite aggressive but
down also rather loose can easily fall
back can I can blow up in your face if
you if you're not cautious yeah not sure
what is Sir what is calculating taking
really really no time him some after 30
moves down to 120 done can do a ping
yeah he's still there
taking a big time out or am I
disconnected to don't I don't think so
no ladies just thinking for a very long
time Wow so um let's see what is coming
up with or maybe he just had a doorbell
ringing or I don't know won the lottery
or something 'if I've yeah this is of
course some very direct way to to go
about that yeah I actually thought I
could I can take okay and if I take on
f6 now I think I should I should do that
really so just look at six only now on
Queen takes on 95 yeah probably just
clean takes yeah let's let's go 35 this
is the most them most active square and
I'm they have not 95 this looks really
dangerous now the night aiming form on
for for these squares okay rook takes is
six here butch x 6ft x e6 okay hmm it's
not so great rook takes g6 you can take
with the f porn it doesn't really amount
to much i can i can just um and pile up
a more pressure here
hmm Luke takes 6-8 doesn't seem to win
strangely enough I mean probably eight
wins in some way but it's not like it's
um it's a media disaster now okay black
like a not too much anyway and he's down
to 20 seconds I just have now okay don't
want don't want to give up the material
now they're just centralized and nice
getting a slight counterplay can let's
attack f7 i have 7 a-3 problem so i can
take maybe just this and now rook f7 and
then then disable at the end yeah this
should one
yeah not not probably not the most
precise way of converting this but
somehow he he spent the ages here close
to three minutes in this position I mean
it's not not not easy to play him but
them it's certainly not so terrible like
black scores has some yeah well too many
pieces forum for such little space um
and this means that some not easy to
handle but certainly a.m. he had better
waste then then what he did I mean if
I've just looks disastrous I mean this
is probably ok but I mean here here he
he needs to do something else computer
wants to play that F take see form with
a good position for black hmm to think
he actually think that my my capture was
a mistake i should go not be three but
ok i didn't think about this move but
this is indeed quite shaky look at this
i mean all my pieces are hanging so
cannot do that here i can play Bishop f6
with computer cell slides what it should
like yeah okay this is of course I mean
this g 4 and f force of course suicide
against the computer because it it's
very tactical and you can easily
overlook stuff yeah thanks for watching
this